today we are looking at a portrait of  stefan hell  who is a german experimental physicist a  nobel laureate  and a researcher who brought about a  revolution in light microscopy  and linda what's the story that you  found most fascinating about  this researcher he's born in romania  and his parents always told him you have  to be as twice as good as the others  then you can't be ignored that was his  measures  and then later on he wanted to break  the wall and turn down the limit of the  resolution of the light microscope  and finally he did it and he got the  nobel prize for that  but we don't see the long way  before you know he had to write 30  applications  to find a job and he told me it needs a  lot of stamina  to go through to all these hurdles  and but finally he succeeded the ball is  broken